thanksgiving is
brace yourself
it's next week
so maybe you're planning your holiday
meal right now oh you might be um but
you know for the valleys less fortunate
that's more of a burden than a blessing
local real estate company working with
project 150 to make sure that every
family has a full thanksgiving feast
this year so important to keep those
dollars here locally so bianca holman
joining us now live to talk about how
you can participate and you can help out
so many folks in need bianca good
morning
hey good morning john good morning
heather do you have your holiday
decorations up already heather i know
you got your tree up at your desk
i know we're all excited but for some
people here in the valley you know what
it is kind of a heartbreaking time and
they don't have the needs and the
resources to make this holiday great but
project 150 is changing that and i'm
joined by kirby schofield with the
realty company so tell me your your real
estate and this nonprofit that helps
teens how are you all partnering
together to help people here in need
thank you so yeah with school for realty
here what we've done is with project 150
we decided as a community what could we
help out with and they've already got it
all figured out like they've been doing
this for almost a decade or over a
decade so what we're doing is every
closing and then our agents are matching
it plus we have outside donations from
social media and stuff we've gotten over
100 dinners already which will feed
roughly 400 almost people and over close
to 2500 already raised wow so how does
it feel to know that you're helping our
teens in need and their families to have
a wonderful thanksgiving that may come
easy for some of us but again so many
people have been hit hard from covid how
does that feel for you it's been
honestly one of the best things like so
with business you're supposed to promote
yourself market yourself but this doing
the post daily about it and then doing
this today
gives you a good feeling it's one of the
best things ever when you get done with
it and then you know each time one of
those things clicks and it says donation
receive or contribution received that
you just fed four people which is
awesome and i know if you haven't
already started doing your just shopping
at the supermarket turkeys they're not
cheap this year okay um so i know that
there are a lot of people out there who
want to donate or if they have some time
to give they they can't financially give
how can some people get par involved so
two different ways one you can if you
have the financial means it's twenty
five dollars feeds a family four you go
to school for realty dot com we have a
banner on top or forward slash turkey
drive easily just click on it though and
then the other way though is on tuesday
and wednesday you can go and help
package the dinners with project 150 for
delivery and that's on the 16th 17th our
team will be there the 17th from like 9
to 12. so if you wanna come and support
us we'd love to see you all right
incredible so it's great to know that no
family no teen
no child will go hungry this holiday
season because if we all work together
again if you're in the private sector
teaming up with a non-profit that we can
make sure that las vegas is fed this
holiday back to you guys in the studio
bianca thank you very much it's so
important to help out during this time
of year during the holiday season
whether it's for thanksgiving for any
any of the holidays doing something is
better than doing nothing yeah and i
mean it is year-round but we always
think about it of course when it comes